hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast titled discover potentially
predictive immuno oncology biomarkers
using next-gen sequencing presented by
Fiona Hyland in Karl Morrison indie
deviance
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots deleting scientific social
networking website and provider virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
is sponsored by the clinical sequencing
division of thermo Fisher Scientific the
clinical sequencing division provides
end-to-end next generation sequencing
solutions powered by iron torrent
semiconductor sequencing technology
adopted by thousands of labs across the
world incited in more than 3000
publications since its launch six years
ago
honoring torrent NGS solutions are
simple fast and flexible making it an
ideal choice for clinical research labs
across the world I'm julissa murasa
blabbers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we start the
presentation we have a few important
announcements to make we welcome your
questions during the webinar
since attendees will be muted during the
presentation please submit any questions
by typing the questions into the
question clock to make be located near
the bottom of your control panel
following the presentation we will
address any questions that were
submitted in the order in which they
were received if when rent over the hour
allotted and do not address your
question we will personally answer your
question by email following the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in a
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and best offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I would
like to introduce Fiona Hyland Fiona
Highland is the director of Informatics
R&D at Thermo Fisher Scientific fiona
majored in genetics as an undergraduate
in Trinity College Dublin and
and quantitative genetics with minors
and statistics and population genetics
as a graduate student at Cornell
University at Thermo Fisher Scientific
fiona's teams have launched tools to
help interpret sequencing data in
clinical research context including
algorithms for tumor normal analysis
genetic disease gene fusion and genetic
annotation please join me in welcoming
Fiona Hyland hello everybody I am going
to talk to you today about the on
combine immune response research assay
and more generally our multi-dimensional
approach to discovering and using
biomarkers are for immunotherapy in
oncology research so we all know that
immune therapies of revolutionising
oncology research we have our checkpoint
blockade a number of drugs are anti pd-1
and PDL one if ii have been approved
therapeutic vaccines are another
approach and there are adoptive t cell
therapies car t cell therapies and many
many more options are in clinical trials
in fact there are more than 800 active
clinical trials ongoing for single or
combinations amino oncology and the
reason for this arm work is is simple
amino therapy is providing the promise
of complete and persistent response in a
way that was not seen with our
traditional therapies or targeted
therapies where typically resistance
would develop after some period of time
and in some proportion of our
individuals persistent our response is
visible with the mean therapies and so
the potential is enormous but the
challenge is understand
the underlying mechanism of action and
identifying biomarkers for understanding
that mechanism of action and for
predicting response to amino therapies
for clinical trials for identification
of appropriate therapies for
identification republic' combination
therapies and so this challenge we
believe demands a multivariate approach
so currently what does it make
stratification a challenge we don't have
complete knowledge of the mechanism of
action there are properties of the to
learn properties of the immune system
and of the immune cells that are very
important but they're not all fully
understood and their interactions are
not all fully understood there are P d1
and PDL one acid but they're not
entirely sufficient for predicting
response IHC assays against PDO 1 are
are quite standard but are not as we
producible as might be desirable and so
we think that there's a grave need to
identify new predictive biomarkers to
help identify patients who may respond
to either single or combination
immunotherapy and indeed also to
identify patients who may suffer adverse
events so that they can be avoided so on
the tumor microenvironment the
properties of the tumor microenvironment
are known to be extremely important in
understanding mechanism of action and in
predicting response to any particular
therapy or combination of therapies and
we are we expected it will not be
sufficient to measure just one or a
small number of properties of the tumor
micro-environment
instead we expect that it will be
necessary to measure a broad range of
signals that identify the properties of
the tumor cells themselves and the
properties of the various immune cells
with the goal
of segmenting individuals likely more
likely to respond or less likely to
respond as well as as well as answer
other important questions and so in
response to this need for understanding
a research level of what are the
properties of the immune system that are
make patients uniquely susceptible to
certain types of immunotherapies we have
developed the on combined immune
response research asking the on combine
immune response research assays is a
next-generation DNA sequencing athlete
it is one of a family of assays that we
have successfully launched and have been
deployed all over the world I know and
why use the common thread in all of
these assays and all of our artistic and
on combined assays our RNA extraction
from FFPE samples for RNA assays
templated templating and sequencing and
these are identical for all of our
others and then the this assay along
with our other assays has specific
designs to enrich for the targets that
we're most interested in and for
analyzing the data so we use the ion
ampliseq library creation technique
which has very many desirable properties
it works on very low amount of input
materials DNA or RNA as little as 10
nanograms of RNA it is compatible with
FFPE samples and it is highly sensitive
to low expressed genes
it has a broad dynamic range and
excellent reproducibility the kit
includes also the analysis so our goal
is to make the analysis simple and it
includes powers and reagents for library
construction are in manual or automated
mode
the power consists of assays to measure
gene expression of about 400 genes in an
FFPE sample to identify the tumor
micro-environment
we curated these 400 genes from a number
of sources
we appreciate the suggestions and
consulting from our collaborators
including National Cancer Center Japan
various farmer collaborators the a range
of other on combine our key opinion
leaders and in addition sources such as
the annotation databases like David
Young combined knowledge base clinical
trials.gov and of course a careful
reading of the current literature and so
we finally ended up with 395 genes
including interference signaling genes
cytokine signaling genes T and B cell
signalling genes markers of lymphocyte
subsets immune checkpoint pathways and
targets tumor markers proliferation
markers and a background of housekeeping
genes and these genes are chosen to
support various types of experiments
method of action studies biomarker
identification research and drug
combination research studies more
specifically we have annotated our genes
into 36 annotation functional
annotations
these are annotations are available to
users of the panel and they include a
number of genes involved in lymphocyte
regulation involved in cytokine
signaling and you can see the details
here involved in immune cell markers
involved in checkpoint pathways involved
in tumor characterization and we have a
number of spark genes that are involved
in all of these pathways
and that are expected to be mutually
correlated so I'm going to show you some
technical data first so one of the very
intense focus areas that we identity
when we develop a panel is we focus a
lot on the technical performance of an
assay and we believe that having we're
both technical performance is very
important to further enable biological
and clinical research questions this is
an example of some data on various
samples the top row is the technical
concordance reproducibility between
fresh frozen samples the second row is
the technical reproducibility between
FFPE samples and the third row is the
technical reproducibility between an
FFPE sample and it's matched fresh
frozen sample and as you can see
concordance is very high in all of these
cases and we compare that to the
concordance between two different
samples in this box and you can see that
as one would expect the concordance is
much lower indicating that the variants
associations with technical
reproducibility is far lower than the
variants associated with a biological
signal confirming that the asset can be
used for measuring biological signal
another kind of technical validation and
verification that we perform is
concordance with orthogonal technologies
and so what we want to see is that the
gene expression measurements that we
observe with our athletes the next
generation sequencing assay based on our
PC technology is consistent with
measurements of those same genes with a
different technology in this context we
use qpcr as the orthogonal technology
which is widely recognized as a gold
standard and these are examples of
the concordance between those two
technologies on a non small cell lung
cancer FFPE samples and to controls and
this is absolute expression so these are
plots look look a very nice little cafe
a high concordance you might be used to
seeing this kind of concordance for
relative expression but not for absolute
expression which typically different
technologies give fairly different
answers what we observe here is we
observe very high concordance between
the qPCR on the x-axis and the uncommon
immune response essay on the y-axis and
this is true across the various FFPE
samples for all of these genes and also
for the controls another technical study
that we did was a dilution series so we
took two samples expected to have
different levels of gene expression for
these 400 genes and did a serial
dilution we diluted them into each other
so that the samples were present at
different ratios and from that study we
can predict the relative and the
absolute differences in expression
between the different samples of the
dilution series and so this plot shows
you on the left the absolute fold change
estimates observed versus expected and
on the right the relative flow change
estimate observed versus expected and
what you can see is that we see a strong
linearity we see high dynamic range we
see low variability and most importantly
we see that these desirable properties
are true for genes that are high
expressive median expresses and also no
expresses so we've colored the various
genes by their expression levels letters
a high expressor and the green color is
our no expresses
and you can see that this pattern of
linearity hiking core high high
correlation with what success with the
expected values and large dynamic range
are true equally for the low expresses
as for the high expresses this is very
important because low expresses include
very many genes of extreme importance
for clinical research and we want to
make sure that the performance of our
assay is very robust for the low
expressing genes as well as higher
expressing genes in this plot we show
examples of a number of different
samples
terney different non small cell lung
carcinoma FFPE samples the left plot
shows the expression level of three
genes and you can see that these genes
are correlated with each other as one
might expect these are cd8 cells T cell
markers and what we would expect is that
for a sampled having enriched C D cd8
cells we would see lower high expression
for those not enriched with cd8 cells T
cells we would see low expression and
that indeed is what we see on the right
hand side this graph shows the
correlation of the of markers for killer
T cells across these same 30 FFPE
non-small cell lung carcinoma cat
samples and again you can see that the
genes that you expect to be mutually
correlated with each other for killer T
cells indeed are strongly mutually
correlated with each other and so this
exemplifies the value of a panel based
approach with a large number of markers
rather than having to make one
measurement on one marker and relying on
one value you can make measurements on a
large number of genes that are expected
to be highly mutually correlated and all
of that data reinforces each other and
indeed this is what we see
once we were satisfied with the
technical performance of the update we
wanted to explore its properties on some
samples this is an example of the
utility of the panel to stratify sampled
by chill levels because of the content
of the panel we expect that we will be
able to identify samples with high till
and differentiate those from samples
with low till you can see that the high
stool samples are marked in red we have
technical replicates three technical
replicates and first you can see the
detecting electric replicas or kelso
very tightly together which is which is
good and what we want to see and in
addition you can see that the high chill
samples also clustered together within
our cell type again this is exactly what
we want to see we want to be able to
differentiate high till from low till
sample and we demonstrated that the si
has the capacity to do this
we compared the assay with another
similar update on the Nano string we
designed an experiment to study these 10
samples or different kinds of samples
breast fed neck melanoma non small Sun
but non small cell and renal cell
carcinoma
nano string was performed by a
third-party CRO that runs nano string
routinely and we performed the immune
response a fake and what we observed was
that the distribution of expression of
genes in the power was nicely bimodal in
the Anka mine immune response Powell
but not so much with the Nano string
panel so each one of these lines is a
single sample representing the
expression of all of the genes in the
power for that sample the blue lines
show the are combined immune response
Ave the black lines shown on a string
what we want to see is a bimodal
distribution two peaks that are distinct
from each other the left peak is genes
that are not expressed centered at zero
and the light peak is genes that are
expressed and what this bimodal
distribution clearly demonstrate is the
ability of the athlete to distinguish
genes that are expressed from genes that
are not expressed so you don't want to
have noise background noise at the low
end impede the ability of the assay to
identify expression or non expression
for low expressed genes or to compete
the ability to distinguish between lower
and higher expression of low expressed
genes the alkaline immune response our
security has these two peaks is bimodal
distribution and an addition has a
higher dynamic range whereas an Alan
string of a does not have such a cure
bimodal distribution indicating that
it's more challenging to distinguish non
express genes from low expressing genes
in addition we can see that the ultimate
immune response Iowa offers higher
sensitivity on genes of interest so the
blue is the immune response and the gray
is the Nano string and you can see that
the immune response that they have
higher sensitivity again this is most
important for low expressing genes where
you want to be able to distinguish
expression from non expression and
changes in expression values and finally
we use the assays to distinguish these
different types of of tumor samples to
confirm that indeed we were able to
perform stratification by clustering on
by tumor type what we found with the on
combine immune response essay is that we
were are the algorithm was able to
clearly cluster the different sample
types whereas in an a string we didn't
see quite such a clean ability to
distinguish the sample types reflecting
the perhaps the content and the
performance relatively speaking of deep
of the two FS
in summary the undermined immune
response assay is a robust sensitive
simple assay to learn we've built in an
analysis solution where we take in the
nine bands and the target region bed
falls into a software suite that comes
with the instrument the immune response
analysis plug-in and we generate summary
statistics QC plots expression and
normalized expression count those are
available from the analysis solution and
they plug in to third-party analysis
tools to perform differential expression
in summary we've offer offering a highly
curated panel with content to assess the
tumor microenvironment and an identified
predictive markers for drug response it
is optimized for FFPE samples and also
works and other kinds of samples with
low input requirements as little as 10
milligrams of total RNA it has high
sensitivity to low expressing genes such
as the interferon family interferon
gamma and has a broad dynamic range with
high reproducibility automated next
generation sequencing workflow that is
simple to operate simple to analyze with
fast turnaround time thank you very much
thank you Fiona
now I'd like to introduce dr. Karl
Morrison dr. Morrison is the president
chief scientific officer and founder of
bonny seek precision medicine technology
he developed the vision for omniseek
while leading this Center for
personalized medicine and division of
molecular pathology at Roswell Park
Cancer Institute dr. Morrison remains a
professor and program member in cancer
genetics at Roswell Park Cancer
Institute he was recently awarded the
Thomas B Tomasi hope award this award is
the highest honor Roswell Park bestows
to the faculty member
his work has made significant advances
in the fight against cancer while
bringing hope to cancer patients dr.
Morrison received his doctorate in
veterinary medicine from the Ohio State
University College of Veterinary
Medicine
followed by his doctorate in medicine
from the University of Kentucky he
completed his residency at the Ohio
State University Medical Center please
join me in welcoming dr. Karl Morrison
thank you very much for being on today
I'm going to follow up very much with
what fiona was saying about technical
performance and these slides that we're
going to be covering will be very much
in line with with how we have validated
this essay in our laboratory so I have
two disclaimers here you can go back and
look at yourself but they're just about
the use of this assay with thermal
Fisher but I really wanted to get into
is how we're using this assay for really
providing precision immunotherapy we are
really have been talking about you know
precision medicine for targeted therapy
research and mutational profiling but
there is you know the personalized
approach for targeted therapy and the
way that Tomic seek is using the
alkaline immune response research essay
is to develop personalized approach for
immunotherapy and there's at least four
buckets that you can put this precision
immunotherapy into and the good part
about that on commodity immune response
I say a tree covers at least three of
these four buckets which is t-cell
receptor signaling which is certainly
one of the most important things because
it's directly related to checkpoint
inhibition I'm going to be called PDL
one signature which is kind of a subset
of t-cell receptor signaling and you can
get the number and the not necessarily
the pattern of immune cells that you can
tell what is the context or of the
different immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment I think we've all seen
this picture a very famous picture by
Genentech disguise the MU lifecycle and
many people have focused on this the
first step in this immune lifecycle or
that is the you know the destruction of
neoplastic cells and release
and that has been described pretty much
as the mutational burden the problem
with the mutational burden is approach
for precision immunotherapy it's just
one one part of this entire immune cycle
and that's the way we've used this
immune response research assay is we
measure mutation mutational burden with
a separate assay which I'll discuss in a
moment but then we use the immune
response research acetate to fill in all
the other various forms of this cycle of
the immune cycle so more specifically
what we do is we take the uncle by the
immune response research assay and
combine that with the comprehensive
cancer panel with thermal Fisher also
offers four mutation burden run that on
the Ion Torrent s5 XL we're running up
to 16 samples per run and test control
our DNA is going from ten to thirty
nanograms RNA and 2 to 10 nanograms
we're not doing confirmations on any
aspect of the testing the entire process
is run on the suite of on torn products
such as the Iron Chef as I mentioned the
s5 XL and the Ion Torrent suite server
what it would be more specific about
which you know is how we measure the
technical performance in our laboratory
in our laboratory is the New York state
laboratories are held to very high
parameters for technical performance I
typically they break this part down into
three buckets pre-analytical analytical
and reproducibility I've listed some of
the various things here that we want
like under pre-analytical what's the
nucleic acid stability and sample form
in other words is someone sending you
understand slides are they sending you a
block and how do you test that RNA
stability and F F versus FFPE you know
thermal fissures claim is this is
effective for FFPE is FF but I think in
every laboratory you need to prove that
for yourself because every FFPE specimen
has different characteristics dilution
with adjacent normal tissue addition of
adjacent necrotic tissue all these
things that could impact the essay on
pre-analytical we'll touch on that not
every one of those
analytical I think I will walk us
through virtually every one of these the
nucleic acid input you know these
encompasses pipetting there's genomic
DNA contamination these areas that occur
during the nucleic acid isolation back
sides right does it matter if you run
two samples or 16 samples did you get
the same answer linearity of the process
right can you demonstrate that you can
detect low expresser moderate express or
high expresses I think Fiona really
focused on the ability to identify low
expresses and I think that's a very
important point that if you go look at
whole transcriptome studies you will see
that whole transcriptome from fresh
frozen tissue really does not work well
at the low expressor multiple reasons
for that but this I say seems to work
extremely well at that point compared to
whole transcriptome and then there's the
sensitivity of baring detection you have
to know what is your limits of detection
in other words do you trust 10 normalize
reads per million or 20 normalize reads
from and what is your cutoff for once
you say this is just background noise
and n reproducibility it's a very
standardized process sometimes it's very
difficult to present the data because
there's so much data and I'll show you
how we present that data we kind of move
away a little bit into what we call the
characteristics of the research
specimens I'm going to touch this you
know what is the phenotype that we're
trying to identify and how do all these
different aspects influence the
phenotype that you're trying to identify
such as the amount of stroma the amount
of tissue the tumor microenvironment
what does it look like I'm going to
start with the most straightforward of
these I think that every laboratory
needs to focus on that is RNA stability
and fresh frozen versus FFPE samples we
published this here very recently an
aqua target using this particular assay
and we took a very very stringent
approach to this and the stringency
reliant basically was on the specimens
so we took fresh frozen tissues that
were large enough that we could bisect
these fresh frozen
issues parallel to the longest axis then
after they were bifurcated we took ink
and put on the face that was up and the
ink surface was mounting face up on a
chuck to cut sections or curls for fresh
frozen and then the FFPE specimen went
through processing and then when it was
mounted in form and paraffin it was
mounted with that ink spot up so that we
knew we were exactly comparing the same
faces of one piece of frozen tissue
versus the same section of FFPE tissue
and this shows 13 samples that we did in
this study that we published as you can
see there is very good correlation
between the FFPE and the FS so this was
our demonstration that FF was concordant
with FFPE the next two things were
nucleic acid input and genomic DNA
contamination these are errors that can
occur in your laboratory and you often
do not know that they're even occurring
you know how how accurate are your
pipetters and I acted on your pipettes
you know are you getting genomic DNA
contamination and what's the impact to
your assay so in this example you can
see here we have a single sample that we
compared doing the results where we
really is about 50 genes here for this
comparison to keep the noise down in the
in the in the figure but the assay was
run with two and a half meta grams of
RNA and with twenty five nanograms of
RNA you know in our recommended input is
10 nanograms of RNA so we were on either
extreme of a pipetting there as you can
see it's concordance between you know a
low RNA input at a higher nee input was
was very good at the same instance we
did genomic DNA contamination and we
went all the way up to 50% you know DNA
contamination and again you can see that
the correlation between presumably no
DNA contamination and 50% DNA
contamination was outstanding if we move
on to backside backsides is so important
because most laboratories you know
you're going to run any type of
this essay you're going to run it you
know probably once a week or once every
other week but you need to know it am I
going to run this with two samples or 16
samples or four samples and we
demonstrated that it really doesn't
matter we took and just it didn't matter
how many samples you put in the assay
because normalization corrected for the
number of samples in the batch so we're
showing one sample here and we're
showing normalized reads for me and on
the on the X act on the x axis we were
showing workers run with 16 samples and
unalaq's as for to run with four samples
and the concordance was quite good the
other thing is is RNA seek with the
library pollution right what happens if
you have a less than optimal sample and
you have less than the recommended
Piccolo's of library so we took one
library and diluted it we rented at the
you know our recommendation is 25 and we
ran into 50 PI Como's and rented at one
point five six PI commode and you can
see the concordance was outstanding so
that you know you can allow for some
pipe engineers and various things to
occur around the library steps and still
get excellent results the next thing and
this we didn't do this just for one gene
but I did pick out you know very you
know common gene and immune on ecology P
do one or cb2 74 to demonstrate right
that the detection of this gene was
linear across a dynamic range in this
instance we took six different samples
each of which had a different level of
expression a PDL 1 and then we surly
deleted the samples with each other and
as you can see it at this point this is
absolute reads it's not normalized risk
if it was normalized these plots since
they are highly concordant would become
horizontal but as you can see the
expression across the deletions was
outstanding and when you get to the very
lower limits you can see here that we
get somewhere down around 20 reads or so
we get into the noise where we can no
longer detect it but outstanding results
for PDL 1
we're moving on into this
reproducibility anytime we do assay
development our site we always have a
positive sensitivity control and we make
sure we run that positive sensitivity
control in every run so we experience of
sensitivity control we experience
experimented with many different cell
lines to find one that highly expressed
the majority of the genes that are in
this panel so we tested several cell and
we always take the cell lines and you
know turn them into a pelletized form
and then take them to a processor and
drink them just like any other FFPE
samples as you can see this is the for
this particular cell line that we
eventually chose as our positive
sensitivity control we ran it for 43
different runs and the correlation
across all the different runs was just
outstanding and I was talking about
reproducibility so there's intra run
into run between technician between days
between barcodes we didn't do between
instruments here because at that time we
are running all this on one s5 excel but
as you can see here this is the way we
always present our information in a
graphical form we take this information
you don't put the detail information
over in Excel files but this is easy for
the reviewer or the viewer or anyone who
wants to review your technical
performance to see how we've done this
and you can see how we've had you know
different technicians different days
different runs and we used three
different specimens plus a replica of
the third specimen and you can see the
concordance is outstanding and it's even
really good for the replicates of this
specimen three-button I'm not really
going to go into clinical validity and
clinical utility but I didn't want to
just kind of touch phone you know how do
we know that what we're looking at is
what we're looking for but we had
originally took an observation from
whole transcriptome analysis looking for
a particular phenotype and on the right
hand side shows this thing to type from
whole transcriptome analysis and as you
can see in this excite here anything
that's red is high expression
low expression you can quickly start to
see that there's basically you know high
express or very low express errs and
moderate expresses and that's what we
used that type of an analysis high low
and moderate to say what is the
influence of specimen characteristics on
this pattern and to do that we did that
primarily with principal component
analysis and we asked lots of questions
about specimen characteristics up if no
way we can get through all of them today
but I think things you need to know
about the immune phenotype is does it
matter what type of specimen you're
testing so you know you can get a
specimen that is essentially a cell
block so it's totally disaggregated you
really can't tell the tumor from the
stroma and sometimes it's difficult to
recognize you know what's the percentage
of stroma in the percent tumor we see
these small needle core biopsies are
extremely small to get disrupted they
just look like little islands of tumor
and a biopsy then we see some that are
partially intact and then we get
research samples that are intact and
when we did our validation we did this
with several hundred samples I think I'm
showing 167 in this graph and you can
see here from principal component
analysis in the first two dimensions
right that there is no bias for any one
of these types of specimen architectures
to have influenced the signature that we
were seeing among low moderate and high
express errs we looked at the same thing
and this was kind of a I'll be a little
bit of a surprising result to us I was
predicting that amount of stroma that
was in the sample would have an
influence on this expression of these
signatures but we compared samples by
pathology review we mark the samples as
abundant stroma moderate stroma modest
stroller or Strummer that's really not
apparent almost like solid sheets of
neoplastic cells and principal component
analysis again did not say that there
was a remarkable difference in any of
those characteristics we look at
specimen size right we've actually
measured the specimen size right and put
it into specimens that were less than 10
millimeters square between 10 and 25 25
to 100 and
greater than 100 millimeter squares so
the letter to or kind of resection
specimen the 10 to 25 is typically a
needle core you're less than 10
millimeters typically something that's
like a needle core block that's been
heavily used right so again we rely on
principle component analysis and show no
difference in those type of those
specimen characteristics influencing the
moderate or the high or the low
expresses this was probably one of the
most interesting things that we did in
this validation from a technical
performance and people always ask this
question right what is the appropriate
specimen to test for immunotherapy
because sometimes a patient let two
specimens in an archive and they have
three or four maybe only one but what
happens when you do that so apologises
labels over laying in the top mark the
top half of this figure is what we call
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes core and
in the bottom half of this figure is
what we refer to as the T cell receptor
score but as you notice there are 16
patients in this study and the patients
are listed along the bottom there and
there's a results for one patient are
listed vertically and as you can see
here if we were to look here here is one
patient here that has three samples and
they were separated by approximately two
years apart and the T cell receptor
signaling score across all three samples
was nearly identical the same patient
when we looked at the tail score was
highly concordant and then we see some
samples that are very concordant like
this and then we see some samples that
are not so concordant and like here is
an example of a sample that was not so
concordant and roughly what we did we
got done with these six these 35 samples
and 16 patients they're roughly divided
into two groups about patho more highly
concordant like this patient and others
that i've marked and then there were
about half of them that were like this
patient or this patient which are not as
concordant and it's the same thing for
teals or the T cell receptor score we
thought this was chemotherapy effect
moving looked up chemotherapy for these
samples and there was no correlation and
if you really look down into details
what you'll find here is that the most
recent sample for all these patients
except one that had a difference in the
interpretation of the amount of t-cell
receptor signaling are the amount of
teals the more recent specimen was
always the lower the lower quantifiable
sample and it really came down to tumor
burden so the tumor burden is
suppressing the immune system but with a
very very exciting specimen study for us
but it all came back down to what is the
appropriate specimen the test the
appropriate specimen test is the most
recent because that's the one that's
most of most in line with the patient's
current immune state is this was our
validation there's a quite extensive
validation I'm certainly going have time
to touch upon lots of it but you know
we've been really happy with this assay
we really like its performance among low
expresses and then the you know anyone
who's working in the immune response
we're chasing that interferon gamma
signature and it's just full of low
expresses and you know the assay does
have you know cancer testes antigens
type genes that are the iPhone so in
their own are extremely high and they're
off they're just you know there's hardly
no expression all it performs just as
well for the only off signatures as it
does for the low expression signatures
but it's really I think it's strength is
in these low expression signatures and
something you know get out of whole
transcriptome I do think that is all the
slides I think it's time that we proceed
to take questions
thank you dr. Morrison due to the
technical difficulties we will be
addressing questions via email following
the presentation again we apologize for
the technical difficulties and we'd like
to thank you for your patience before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October 25th
2017 you will receive an email from lab
groups letting you know when this
webcast will be available for
play please share that announcement with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you both once again that's all for
now thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon bye